earlier this week the council held its
monthly meeting for November it started
with a presentation from Sam hull who
was representing the ownership of
Pegasus Golf Club he updated the council
about Pegasus hosting the NZ PGA
Championship Tournament for the next
three years and talked about future
plans to construct accommodation and
conference facilities at the golf course
[Music]
the council also formally adopted the
caillou town center plan 2028 and beyond
it promotes a vision of a vibrant town
center that embraces the river attracts
visitors and new businesses and creates
enjoyable public spaces for the first
time it also includes master plans for
the mix juice business areas that were
set aside following the Canterbury
earthquakes because of the large amount
of land available for development that's
considered a long-term plan and could
take the next 20 to 30 years to be fully
realized the council also approved a
submission on behalf of the Waimakariri
district to the draft regional public
transport plan this document plans for
the region's public transport needs for
the next 10 years and beyond our council
strongly advocated for higher frequency
services between christchurch and our
main towns we also ask that the
committee be more ambitious and trialing
new transport technologies and
developing demand responsive services
for our smaller or more remote
population centers the final monthly
council meeting for the year will be
held on Tuesday the 4th of December
[Music]